Let's go next to our caller from the five,
six, three area code.
Who is calling today from five, six three.
I was a grill.
Did you say this is Earl.
Oh, bill.
Hey bill.
What's up?
Um, I'm just concerned.
I, I live in Iowa.
You know, one of our senators is Senator Grassley,
right?
And one of his only defense is about
why the,
no, it was good for us with taxes included.
It's bad to demonize the rich.
And why would that come out if that's not
true?
One,
the millionaires in the world, they unbalanced
the whole thing.
Yeah.
This is a talking point.
It's not just Grassley who is used that talking
point.
And I've actually seen, you know, this is
why it's great when you have groups like patriotic
millionaires and others come out and say,
this isn't about demonizing rich people.
This is just about recognizing that they got
rich in part because of public infrastructure
and because of the labor of others and because
of the regulatory environment.
So we just want people paying what's fair
and not unbalancing the economic system in
a way that's destructive.
It's not, there's no, you know, there was
that billionaire dude, I played the clip from
CNBC a few months ago who was like almost
cry.
I think he was crying in the segment about
Elizabeth Warren's mean to rich people.
It's not about individuals, it's just about
we need a system that balances out and that
works
and balances out so it doesn't carry on like
a oligarch for life.
Yeah.
To
and his brother.
Yeah.
And these people look at Trump's spawn.
I mean, these people are going to carry on
billions of dollars of influence.
Yeah.
With nothing behind them.
No doubt.
I know.
Anyway, I just thought it's, it's odd when
they, that's their only defense.
I totally agree with you.
And I'm hearing myself on a three second delay
on some kind of device, so I'm going to let
you go.
I really appreciate the call and hope to hear
from you again.